when they're no such thing their
partisan critical theory hacks who think
they can destroy everything America
stands for by standing on the sidelines
and sniping at patriotic Americans with
all their favorite slurs they have
nothing but contempt for the American
people might be a bit overwritten but if
you remember Andrew Breitbart you
understand his style so where does that
leave us is what Trump doing good
the press are still a vital institution
we need transparency and accountability
among our leaders and the press are the
institution in America best position to
do that they haven't been doing that I
don't know where this war goes what
should have happened after 2016 was
apologies from media outlets for how
poorly they cover the election and how
they treated Trump voters there should
have been a realization that their
narrative setting agenda pushing
propaganda was not conducive to civil
discourse they should have stuck to
facts and not spinning them or torturing
facts into unrecognizable caricatures of
themselves should have hired from
outside of their tiny bubbles instead
apart from a few mayor culpas here and
there the media reinforced their
problems instead of firing their worst
reporters they promoted them or hired
them away they didn't make any
structural changes so this is the
problem we face and challenge before us
the implosion of media credibility is a
crisis the ones who need to fix it are
unwilling or unable to do so and the
health of the Republic is at stake so on
that cheery note I'm happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
I think why don't you take another
question for there are some mics if you
would use those please
I saw a picture of Donald Trump
attacking actually don't know what was
motion graphics working but how does
that actually differ from a political
cartoon in the same deference to say Tom
tolls
cartoons and yeah it was he this is when
President Trump tweeted out on Sunday
was a short video clip that had been
doctored so that it it was originally a
wrestling event that had been videotaped
and had been doctored so it appeared
that Donald Trump who actually was in
the original is that right we were live
in such weird times don't we so that
that the victim now was the CNN head I
don't think that that people found the
product itself so out of bounds so much
as who was sending it and it is
absolutely true that this his behavior
that we have not seen before not just
from presidents but Republican
presidents you know you compare this way
of responding to media attacks with how
George W Bush responded which is to say
he didn't respond and how did that work
out for him you know you can judge that
or how you how you judge his ability to
to withstand critiques from others but
it is very interesting I thought that
the the line that dr. Spaulding
mentioned was very interesting when he
said it's not presidential
it's modern-day presidential I was
talking with a bunch of reporters about
that and they said yeah well I guess he
is tweeting in a way you know he tweets
a lot and that is modern-day
communication style it's like I don't
think that's what he's saying I think
what he's saying is he is attempting to
lead a country where one of the problems
is the inability of established order to
respond to change and he's willing to
punch through those norms he's willing
to fight what you need do things that
you were not supposed to do in order to
to make a change you know whether you
like that or you don't like it is an
entirely different issue but I think
what he was saying was that a president
Lee
and if the media are creating a problem
and many people think that the media
have not been doing a good job covering
issues in this country or helping out
with civil discourse he's the guy who
will take them on
thank you very much I wanted to make a
statement and see if you agree and if
you do why and if you don't well let's
make it the media is more powerful than
ever do you agree with that and if you
do do you think do you have ideas for
steps as to how to reduce its power or
do you disagree and if you disagree why
the media are more powerful than ever
it's such a complicated topic that I
would like to reflect on it a little bit
but I mean before answering but I don't
have that luxury so here we go but I do
think that there are aspects of changes
in technology that have created both a
moment of greater power for the media
and then also their attacks on media
power that that these advances in
technology have also led to so we have
seen how media messages and this sort of
like generally held opinions held by
elite media establishments can change
things quite dramatically and they'll
push an agenda and they will they will
just keep in sort of an unrelenting
fashion until they achieve their goal
that's powerful that's incredibly
powerful or even creating an environment
where people are afraid to speak out
which is why I think what happened with
CNN this week was so telling it's
something that people actually feel a
lot that if they hold views different
from the elite media consensus that they
might be held up for ridicule and so
when CNN actually literally went after a
guy like Iran random person who dared
mock their media outlet it felt like no
that's what we feel like you have been
doing and it was very threatening so
they hold a lot of power at the same
time you've never had people hold so
much power against that domination with
the decentralization that social media
provides and with the ways that
different people are trying to respond
to it so I don't know I think it's a
complicated topic and I do think
technology is a major reason why with
social media changing things like you
used to as a journalist start out at a
publication
you kind of knew your way up to the top
and you were known for the quality of
your work and if it were if you did a
good job you could go up through the
ranks from a low market paper to a high
market paper and now with social media
you just have journalists just showing
everybody all the time what they're
biased views are and they kind of create
a name for themselves as apart from the
any publication or TV outlet they're
with and it's it's just very complicated
time so anyway yes I'll think more on it
and we'll have a chat about it later but
yes make the short step I'm not
splitting agree so I have a problem with
saying that the media bias is problem
why because the premise that media was
ever not biased is a false premise
Prem Media was always biased because
journalist was always were always biased
but because few publication of radio TV
controlled the information flow the
useful ideology was who they are not
biased so you all have to listen to us
so in a sense I think now it's kind of
what happened with labeling in the food
stores now we can see the calories which
we have information it's an honest
labeling of the sources of media and we
can now make a choice whether we want to
listen to this kind of media or this
kind of fun but that's kind of more
honesty now okay so I agree and disagree
in part so it is absolutely true that
there's always been bias and that that's
and in fact this period that we've seen
in the last few decades where people
claim to be objective they claim to be
non biased that's a real blip even in
American history it's completely unheard
of in other countries where people are
just open about their biases that they
have and I think we're pretty clearly
obviously going right into that more
European model of of the media it does
come at a cost though one of the critics
that I pointed out says that it's
important to have a shared set of facts
and that is absolutely true it helps to
have a debate where you can all come
together on it on
some some place of agreement some place
where you agree that this is the matter
at hand that needs to be discussed or
these are the actual facts in play and
when you have a completely balkanized
media where everyone's just admitting to
their biases and everyone's just
speaking to people who share their own
views you don't get a lot of that good
civil discourse that good cross
discussion that is very important for a
public we are very different people we
have very different ideas and obviously
pretending that things were objective
and that pretending people were unbiased
and that these different viewpoints
would get fair play in that environment
that that's not happening but it's not
necessarily a good move to go into a
more to a more tribal eyes space so it
comes at a cost
great speech thank you what can be done
what should be done more whatever to
target those people who still have a
little bit of intellectual integrity for
them to actually erase just raise the
question of what am I being told here
when they listen to the regular liberal
media because if they just ask
themselves the questions they'll see
that what they're being fed is
completely disconnected I mean I myself
just put a sign sometimes on the back of
my car that says not yet sick of liberal
media's PC lies just to make people
wonder like hey have I been lied to and
what you know what could because I think
I think they need to go I mean any to
self-destruct and disappear basically I
mean and and at this point it just of
course there's always going to be people
don't do to dishonest to a face up to
reality but still there's a big segment
of the population that needs to know
wise enough so I think that this is
where the topic of Trump versus the
media is very interesting the arrival of
Trump on the political scene in earnest
a couple years ago I mean he's been
there he's been there lurking for a long
time but it really has been a
transformative and district highly
disruptive event what happened in the
conservative environment was very
difficult and the best advantage that
conservatives Republicans have is that
they had a very long period of time to
deal with what Trump was doing to their
party what he was doing to the movement
there was a lot of anguish and angst and
people didn't quite know how to respond
and then by the end he wins the election
and he has pretty much everybody on
board and on the right notable
exceptions in DC and Manhattan but they
had a long period of time when you think
about what happened for the rest of the
country can you imagine what that was
like for people to wake up the morning
after the elections and the one thing
they knew would not happen like they
didn't know exactly how things were
gonna go but the one thing they knew and
they felt very confident and secure in
that that didn't happen and they wake up
and then all of a sudden they have to in
overnight do what Republicans and
conservatives were doing for years which
was coming to terms with wait this is
real this is really happening
and so sometimes I reflect on how people
are reacting so hysterically to the
election of Donald Trump but I try to
also remember they didn't have that
lengthy period of time to get adjusted
now that it's July I do feel like we
need to kind of step it up a little bit
but part of what you're seeing with the
angst I think and part of with like
media not knowing how to respond to the
moment is them working out some of these
issues that you're talking about they're
trying to understand who do we believe
who do we trust what is news how to
cover these things and I don't know how
well they're doing but they are
struggling and the struggle is itself
you know it's going to be difficult for
a lot of people but hopefully they will
get to a healthier place soon thank you
I'm a teacher and what do you suggest
when I am in front of all my students
and they're asking me about the media
and I am trying to stay unbiased as
possible but you know you're going to
sources and they're researching what do
you suggest for somebody like me in a
position that I'm supposed to be
unbiased but at the same time trying to
teach them to be neutral I think this is
why so many people are frustrated with
the ubiquity of anonymous sources in
coverage of the Trump administration
teaching people how to respond
critically to a story that they see read
or hear is very important and something
all Americans should do as it's just a
function of being good healthy members
of the Republic but the way you do it is
by checking facts that are put in the
story and you look at regional sources
to see if they were conveyed accurately
you look and you think through like what
you think through your natural
objections that you might have to a
certain storyline and were those natural
objections placed in the story or not
when you see such over reliance on
anonymous sources which by definition
cannot be checked for accuracy I mean I
referenced that CNN's story where we
were told that James Comey would testify
under oath by people very close to him
which usually is code for Comey
that or you know you thinking real close
to Comey they said things that were
completely not true what happened to
those sources what happened to that
story why were we not told what went
wrong there who messed that up were the
sources who gave the false information
outed which is a which is something that
you can do if a source lies to you you
can reveal their name no they didn't
even talk about it so it's very hard to
to accept or trust a given story when
media outlets aren't providing that kind
of transparency that would be very
helpful right now but in general I like
I grew up in a town with two newspapers
the Rocky Mountain News and then we're
post and it was awesome for learning how
to evaluate news stories you'd read how
they print how one reporter handled one
event you'd read how another reporter
handled an event you'd see they had
completely different takes they saw
different things that would just kind of
open up your mind to the possibility
that one's perspective can color how
they treat a given news story so I would
say that that's one thing that you could
do is just encourage people to look at
various different sources on a given
story so if it's like a hearing that's
being covered look at how all the
different people cover that hearing or
even a sporting event you can get a much
different reaction from multiple
reporters compare and contrast
do you have a feel on how the
advertisers are responding to all this I
mean that's a really great question
that's probably very significant and I
don't actually know the answer to that
at all I I do think that one thing that
like the political left has been very
good at is weaponizing Commerce or
weaponizing advertisers and it probably
isn't going to take too long before the
right figures out that that's an
effective method to so you see it in
some political situations like having
heads of major corporations bully
legislators into doing things that their
citizens don't want because they
threaten economic consequences or you
see sometimes people campaign to harm
advertisers on certain shows or whatnot
well that's kind of a game that can go
both ways I don't think it's
particularly healthy game by the way but
also if a media outlet really loses its
credibility
I think the funders and the advertisers
will start to take things much more
seriously which we might actually see
what happens there pretty soon
oh okay yes ma'am my name is Camry but
under the Pakistani Spectator and my
question is do you see any inverse
relationship between media going after
President Trump and his fan liking him
more am asking this question because as
a journalist I asked this question to
many people especially the people who
are from other countries they tell me
that if they believe in media he should
not have won the election on first place
and even after he won the election he
should have been off the scene long time
ago
Thanks yes the the thing I like to say
is that the media and Donald Trump are
in a kind of dysfunctional codependent
relationship so they both feed off of
attacking the other it works out well
for both of them I mean Donald Trump
made it to the to the White House by
attacking the media clearly that's
that's working at the same time ratings
are off the hook for a lot of TV
networks and subscriptions are up people
are enjoying the media's battle against
Trump as well so they don't really have
strong incentives to change what they're
doing and yes the anger that I talked
about is so serious among certain
sectors of the American public the ones
that are frequently among the most
marginalized from newsrooms
that the more he attacks the media the
more that they feel he's doing it on
behalf of them like they really feel
that they were brutalized by the media
so when they see someone finally
punching back it's not something that
they're going to be upset about on the
other hand if you're already a critic of
Trump you look at this and you think
this is dangerous this is horrible this
is exactly what we worried about so it's
it's not a healthy situation
particularly because nobody has an
incentive to change right now
I really appreciated your practical
solutions so thank you for dealing with
media and the press when and why do you
think it became so slanted and is there
anything different about Trump not
necessarily worse but is
anything particular to his presidency
that is I don't know an anomaly like
anything I know nothing at all I noticed
anything different everything seems
normal
well no that's and I and I do go into
this in the broadside that this
breakdown in trust really occurred over
decades so people keep thinking this
Trump event is singular that this is the
thing we all need to focus on but really
credibility for the media was declining
for a long time before there were
problems on major stories and everyone I
actually asked this one time of people
what was something that caused you to
lose trust in the media and the
diversity of responses was astounding
like a lot of people really didn't like
Katrina coverage I don't even
some for some people it happened quite
recently so you remember the Rolling
Stone published a cover story as part of
a national campaign it was pretty
obvious there was a national campaign by
certain liberal groups to make college
campus rape a big issue and so as part
of that campaign they ran a front pay or
you know cover story on how at UVA there
was this brutal gang rape and at first
the story which was written by Sabrina
Rubin aired early I think is how you say
her last name received wide acclaim I
mean people were just praising it up and
down this is brilliant piece of
journalism it's amazing turned out to be
a hoax from the accuser that should have
been caught a hundred times over by the
reporter it wasn't made it through
editing channels it was a complete
disaster and they had to pull the story
they're facing major lawsuits before it
was revealed that it was a hoax story
the fraternity I think had been kicked
off campus there were real problems
because of these falsehoods that were
spread through this story but seeing how
a powerful media institution like
Rolling Stone supported by various other
media amplifying voices could push this
agenda when it was all based on nothing
I think it a lot of people woke up to
some problems there should also be
pointed out that that story was exposed
fraudulent first and foremost by an
independent blogger who had been an
editor who just said it smelled fishy he
was attacked mercilessly for food saying
this there was a reporter reason who dug
into it who also had some questions he
was also attacked by the time the
Washington Post was raising some
questions people realized that there was
a big problem and in fact it was the
Washington Post in particular and a few
other media outlets that did a good job
of holding that publication accountable
so it would be nice also when people are
criticizing what's happening in the
media in terms of pushing narratives
that they also realized the importance
of having good critical responses in
that same media environment as well and
that's why it's important you know I
think a lot of people see just the
negative that comes from major media
establishments and there's a lot of
negative there's also important
strengths they have to
miss Hemmingway Davy Talbot thank you so
much for your thoughtful remarks curious
to know what your summer reading
recommendations are that's a really
that's a great question for which I
should have better answers first off my
husband and I have been reading through
Shakespeare a little bit every day it's
a good thing you can get through in a
year there's a who's I forget it's at
Matthew Schmidt's who put it together No
ah so bad with names I'm so sorry
yeah oh my gosh anyway you can find it
at first things there's a daily reading
guide and I highly recommend it I am
reading because all things Russia are so
fascinating I'm reading that Nobel
laureates work to remember her name
it's called I'm so bad at this big book
on Russia that everybody loved two years
ago it's called secondhand memories or
something like that it's very very
interesting and then yeah I don't know I
should all think of something in a few
minutes and then I'll get back to you I
think you push back on this tonight on a
panel but the common conservative
establishment narrative is that Trump is
going instead of hurting his agenda by
these these war with this war with the
media yeah you made a very compelling
case of why it would be just for a
conservative minded politician who loves
this country to try to attack that or
break down the media's power do you are
you opening idea that it's part of his
agenda to do something for the media or
to break that power or do you how you do
not buy into that yeah that was so on
special report the other night we were
talking about Donald Trump's tweets and
it was actually Charles Lane of the
Washington Post who pointed out that
attacking the media is part of Donald
Trump's agenda so people say is it
distracting from his agenda when he
tweets out attacks on CNN he was like
this is a major part of his agenda and
there are many reasons why that would be
a major part of this agenda so if you
look at Wow like it's almost surreal to
look back on the major media themes
leading up to this point we have
actually had six plus months of straight
up
Styria on russia based on I will admit
that it does seem like maybe outgoing
people did a really good job of giving
the impression that there was something
there but at some point you kind of have
to ask is there any fire here other than
you people running around with your
heads on fire you know like is there any
actual thing here we've had Washington
Post CNN and a few other outlets really
pushing something that is not I don't
think I mean uno maybe maybe it'll turn
out I play this game sometimes where I
joke about what would be the craziest
ending to 2017 and mine would be that
Putin really did like or that Russians
really did create a Manchurian Candidate
like 80 years ago and Donald Trump is
actually a stooge of Russia and he's in
the White House like that would be a
hilarious if scary ending to 2017 but
barring that barring that unlikely
outcome it seems like we've had a lot of
time wasted on something that's not very
good to waste time on so if you're
trying to have another agenda and you've
got the media actually pushing this
story yeah you need to push back on that
so it is part of his agenda and then
even more than that I found the the
wrestling meme to just be utterly
fascinating I've been watching glow so
if you're not reading but if you're
watching anything the summer glow I
highly recommend is for gorgeous ladies
of wrestling and it's on Netflix and
it's about a real 1980s era women's
wrestling thing that was happening so I
was not a wrestling fan in that in that
time or later so I've been learning a
lot about the the art or the sport of
wrestling and one of the things in this
TV show is like this character in it
realizes she's a former soap actress she
realizes at some point that this is all
soap opera and once she says oh it's
soap opera I can now play this part
because I know how to do soaps I'm gonna
be the good girl she's going to be the
bad girl
we're gonna have these like cartoonish
storylines or whatnot so Trump tweets
out this wrestling Jif and it seemed
oddly self-aware
of what what is going on here
meta-narratives about how he knows that
he needs to have a heal while he's going
to be the hero or whatnot and so he
picks out different different victims
and this goes back to that codependent
dysfunctional relationship I was talking
about but yeah it's part of his agenda
it also enables him to accomplish other
things if he can direct these sort of
large storylines where they're good guys
and bad guys thank you I really enjoyed
the talk so far PolitiFact fact-checker
or the Pinocchio's of of our of our
media how effective do you think they've
been it depends on what you think their
goal is I guess if their goal was to
discredit media fact-checking they have
been incredibly effective if their goal
I mean actually my husband Mark
Hemingway has here has written
extensively about fact-checking and some
of the problems they're in and I highly
recommend his work on it but one of the
things he points out is that
fact-checking came out of this
environment where George Bush had won
re-election and the media really felt
like that should not have happened and
they felt if only the people had is like
the fake version of CNN's quote if only
they had the facts then we would have
had our way and the country would have
been saved so they set up this these
fact checks and then frequently
fact-checked things like predictions
which is impossible to this goes back to
the Michael Crichton essay against
speculation where you can't fact check a
prediction about the future or they fact
check opinions when they fact check even
things that could have been fact check
they didn't really do a good job with
balancing the weight of evidence or what
not then there's my husband's favorite
example that they six times gave the
claim if you like your health care plan
always if you like your health insurance
you can keep your health insurance the
fact check that claim true six times in
some form before later ruling it there
lie of the year after Obama won
re-election so in general I think that
there's this aspect of feeling like I
think for some establishment media types
they worry that they're losing control
the narrative they've enjoyed the power
that they had when they were when there
were just a few media outlets and as
things get more diffuse they feel
they're losing control and they think
the thing to do is like build a wall
German Germany style you know to keep
everything in and that they that they
can sort of force people to accept their
narrative fact-checking in that form has
clearly failed so what people should
probably be worried about if they're
worried about freedom of expression or
freedom of the press is them are the
later iterations of that like social
media giants determining what's real
news and what's fake news like Facebook
how they're going to police that and
whether they allow information to be
shared there are some plans that that
certainly raised alarm bells for people
who are concerned about Liberty even as
we are should also all be concerned
about the actual spreading of false
information and fake news yes sir I read
The Washington Post and The Washington
Times and and traveling around it seems
like the major newspapers in Los Angeles
and Boston New York and the Post all
have a very liberal take on the news and
the Washington Times is located here I'm
just wondering how throughout the nation
the other story of what's happening with
Trump and the Trump administration good
things that are happening how does that
get out and is it getting out well I
think this is also part of what many
people find frustrating about Trump's
conquering of social media with his
millions of followers on Twitter and he
also uses other social media forms he is
speaking directly to people with his own
message and it's unfiltered by the media
and again if you're concerned about
truth that that goes that's both good
and that's bad President Donald Trump
not necessarily being known as the most
accurate in every tweet that he sends
but he's able to communicate straight to
people without using these filters the
filters having become too cumbersome or
too shaded or biased against
against certain people so I'm not
entirely sure although I would say the
election in 2016 provides some pretty
good evidence of I mean pretty
conclusive evidence of media messaging
not sinking through to a good portion of
the electorate I mean there was there
was an outright rejection rejection you
might remember the New York Times had a
front page article saying like
journalists have to throw out the
journalism textbooks and how they cover
Donald Trump everything must be done to
stop this person that was an overt
statement that was a very honest
statement I think by the by the guy who
wrote it Jim Ruttenberg explaining that
that was the perspective of a lot of
reporters there were a lot of people who
felt that there were a lot of people who
put their coverage that way it was
considered unacceptable to vote for
Donald Trump the fact that he won is a
good indication that people are getting
their information from means other than
mainstream media last question yes sir I
grew up hearing Walter Cronkite saying
that's that's the way it is
so the breakup of the media seems to be
a good thing at the same time they seem
to have Latin now lost so much
credibility I wonder if they can ever
reestablish it especially given modern
technology you implied a little bit
about this the very beginning what are
the larger implications of that for our
for our country and for democratic
conversation right all presidencies
should be held accountable and they need
to be held accountable for the sake of
the Republic it is important that people
have confidence in their institutions
and that they feel that they can trust
this constitutional system that we have
and obviously the media failed to do
that during the Obama presidency you can
argue about how well or poorly they did
that prior to that but I think there was
a pretty you know good reason to believe
that they completely failed to do that
during the Obama era and now they have
lost credibility and I don't know if it
can come back it's certainly not going
to come back until they accept that they
have a problem and that they need to
make changes and start making dramatic
changes if you ever really wronged
someone
you know that sometimes you need to make
a dramatic show of your remorse and
truly change your ways we I'm Christian
and repentance means to turn away from
what you're doing so when you repent of
a sin you turn away from it you don't
keep doing it so we need to see some
dramatic changes in how the media cover
the people how well they understand
their views and make systemic changes so
that you're not hiring from the same
limited bubble on the island of
Manhattan and inside the beltway that
you think about how to really diversify
the political views in the newsroom that
you make people who don't share the
group think of most of the people in the
newsroom feel comfortable and able to
express those views and the reason why
it's important is because we do need to
have ways of holding people accountable
and it is very hard to get for instance
this White House to be transparent when
you are spending your time you know
hunting down people who made a funny
video mocking your network or talking
about how many scoops of ice cream
the president has versus other people
you know you need to have credibility
because you want to have the voice that
can fight to hold people accountable
like the White House does not release
the names of people who come to visit
them they also didn't really do a good
job with this during the Obama
administration they would have meetings
off-site and whatnot it's really hard to
you know this is something that people
should know who's coming to the White
House and we haven't we don't have a
media that is strong enough or credible
enough right now to push for that type
of transparency and without that a lot
of corruption can can go forth and
people lose confidence and that is not
what we can have an afford in our system
of governance so I really do hope that
people who hold these positions of
authority in the media think about how
to regain their credibility understand
the importance of regaining their
credibility and make some real good
faith efforts even in these difficult
times to do so thank you
[Applause]
c-span's Washington Journal live every
day with news and policy issues that
impact you and coming up Monday morning
dr. Margaret flowers of physicians for a
National Health Program and Michael
Tanner of the Cato Institute will
discuss the feasibility of a
government-funded national health
insurance program also Washington Times
political editor Steven Dinant will talk
about the Trump administration's request
for voter information and reaction from
state officials nationwide be sure to
watch these bands Washington Journal
live at 7:00 Eastern Monday morning
join the discussion now former george w
bush and obama administration officials
on terrorism financing and ongoing
efforts to disrupt those funding
networks operations hosted by the arab
gulf states institute in washington this
is about 90 minutes my name is Marcela
I'm the president here of the our Gulf
states Institute I'd like to welcome all
of you to today's program on financing
terrorism of the many aspects of the
fight against terrorism cutting off the
financial flow is the most critical it
is oxygen that keeps these groups alive
and allows them to recruit control
territory
plan and carry out violent operations on
a global level the issue of terrorist
financing also obviously is at the
center of the current crisis in the GCC
and it remains the top priority for the
US as we seek to defeat Islamic state
and other terrorist groups the US and
its Gulf Arab partners have taken
significant steps to stem the flow of
funds to terrorist groups over the past
15 years really a very robust effort
since 9/11 however despite the various
measures and regulations put in place
terrorist organizations continue to
generate income from the region to
finance their activities what more can
be done three
and globally to stem the flow of money
to violent extremists we have a very
distinguished panel with us today to
answer that question and explore all the
issues related to it I'm pleased to
welcome our guest speakers Juan Zarate
David Cohen and Kate Bauer as well as
our very own executive vice president
ambassador Steve sash who will introduce
the panel and also moderate today's
program again welcome and look forward
to a good discussion today thank you
great thank you so much Marcel and good
afternoon and welcome everyone I am very
pleased to be able to moderate this
discussion and I'm very very happy to
have such distinguished colleagues with
me to help enlighten us on the subject
as Marcel said one of critical interest
and I'm one of a very timely nature at
the moment given events in the region
and here in Washington as well my
introductions will be short you can look
for greater detail in these handy little
programs that were on your chair when
you walked in but allow me to please
just briefly introduce Kate Bauer
who's the bloomin Stein Katz family
fellow at the Washington Institute for
Near East policy and a former treasury
official who served as the department's
financial attache in Jerusalem and in
the Gulf region to her right is David
Cohen the former deputy director of the
Central Intelligence Agency and better
known to me in his role at Treasury
before we joined the CIA when he was
Undersecretary of the Treasury for
terrorism and financial intelligence and
to David Wright is one Zarate the
chairman and co-founder of the financial
integrity Network and I knew one for
some time when he worked as a deputy
assistant to the President and deputy
national security advisor for combating
terrorism from 2005 to 2009 again
further details available here but for
the sake of time at our disposal we'll
get on with the conversation and what
I'd like to be able to do perhaps is
give each of our guests the chance to
look at what the the issue may be in a
larger sense or a larger framing sense
may be here and I'll ask them a question
they can all respond to it and focus on
whatever issues whatever angles they see
as most productive in our conversation
I'm hoping we can get at this from a
bunch of different angles and really
then develop a more full picture of what
we see out in the Gulf
so my question for you and I'll start
with we're gonna do this in reverse
alphabetical order we decide to give
ones a rot day a chance to go first
which you never got when he was in grade
school so that so the question is what
does the the extent of us
counterterrorism and counter-terrorist
finance and cooperation with the Arab
Gulf states collectively bilaterally and
is the cooperation now at risk because
of the deep fissures we see developing
among the GCC states at the moment Steve
thank you very much I want to thank you
and Marcel and the Arab Gulf states
Institute for the invitation to be here
I count myself as incredibly fortunate
to have learned and been in government
when you both were serving and to have
learned at your feet was a it was a
great honor and to to have learned with
David and Kate as well so I'm really
privileged to be here I'm probably the
least of the experts here but I'm happy
to contribute as I can I think there's
been a kind of a natural evolution to
the counter terrorist financing
counterterrorism cooperation between the
u.s. and our Gulf allies and it
obviously started post 9/11 with a
dramatic focus on a much more preventive
framework for dealing with illicit funds
and illicit support to terrorist
organizations and in many ways the early
days of that cooperation was remedying
or dealing with the pre 9/11 framework
for how the Gulf was dealing with groups
that were either tied to al-qaeda or
those that were supporting them and it's
no secret and certainly have been
subject of lots of conferences and
reports as to how we dealt with Saudi
Arabia in those early days dealing with
the reality of deep-pocket donors that
were supportive of al Qaeda or related
groups prior to 9/11 charities and
nonprofit organizations which became a
major subject of attention for the US
and our Gulf allies and then putting in
place the tools and strategies to allow
us to actually prevent groups like al
Qaeda from from gaining support and and
financing from from the Gulf that has
been a story with many chapters to it
but the bottom line is the US has relied
very heavily on that cooperation over
time one that has matured both in terms
of how we deal with financial
intelligence which David can speak to
better than anybody what we've done in
preventative terms to actually create
systems that don't allow row capital to
enter the system at least theoretically
dealing with state sponsorship questions
making sure that there are there's
clarity that states should not find or
create mechanisms to support terrorist
groups and then trying to find ways of
jointly acting against targets that
we've found to be supporting terrorist
groups and so in the early days post
9/11 we had a number of these joint
designations with the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia
that has followed in course we've had
continuous efforts in that same vein
including with Qatar in recent years
thanks to the work of the US Treasury
and so there has been an evolution to
actually focus on this in a fundamental
way and the one thing I would I would
say and this goes to Marcel's point at
the introduction these issues actually
are more fundamental and more important
now than ever before
not just because they form part of this
political rift but because the issues of
how groups like al-qaeda groups like
daesh other successor groups are
actually raising funds running war
economies and developing global networks
is more critical now than ever before
there's been much in the literature
about the the folly of following the
money or trying to deal with terrorist
financing and I think it's the exact
opposite I think it's more fundamental
now to think through how it is that
these types of groups gain support are
able to sustain themselves and actually
are able to build their networks and
their global ambitions because of the
financing that they have that's why
these issues are so important in the
Gulf today and in terms of the rift it's
clear to me that from an American
standpoint the rift is is a burden and a
barrier to cooperation we have built our
counter terrorist financing and
counter-terrorist
a playbook around the idea that we need
strong cooperative allies on the ground
not just in a bilateral context but in a
regional context and when we've had the
most success Steve and in this regard
and you know this well from your work in
particular in in Yemen and elsewhere
where we've had the most success has
been when like-minded allies are working
together to gather intelligence and
information gather around a common
strategy and mission and then figuring
out where there's a division of labor
around the kinds of actions that need to
be taken to deter disrupt and dismantle
terrorist financing networks to the
extent that this rift doesn't allow that
to happen to the extent that it creates
levels of mistrust to the extent that it
ruptures elements of information sharing
that is all not good from an American
perspective and I think anything we can
do to try to repair the relationship to
try to focus on the mission of
preventing terrorist financing is
critical there's lots of complications
of course as to how you define terrorism
what we mean by terrorist financing what
we mean by state sponsorship all of
those issues are implicated by the rift
but I think fundamentally from an
American perspective there is a need to
have global regional and in the case of
the Gulf states GCC level cooperation to
deal with what is still a critical
national and international security
issue thank you so much for honest a
couple of really interesting points
we'll get back to one of which certainly
is the evolving financial model that
some of the organizations are pursuing
now and as well as a kind of collective
GCC versus a bilateral cooperation and
how that breaks down and on the ground
so with that in mind let me go over to
David and ask you David for your view on
this sure and thank you Steve thank you
myself for inviting me to be here you
know as two former ambassadors
who have done great work I think it's
worth at the outset noting how important
it is in all of what we do in terrorist
financing in particularly that we have a
strong and fully functioning and fully
staffed State Department although this
is an advertisement for the Treasury
Department we're all former Treasury
officials the work that we've been able
to do in countering terrorist financing
not to mention many many other areas is
enormous ly dependent on having a state
department that is out there fully
empowered and fully functioning so I can
applaud so just a couple of quick
thoughts picking up on what one was
saying the the effort to combat terror
is financing I came to the Treasury
Department in 2009 at a point where one
and and his his team with Stuart Levey
and others at Treasury had made enormous
amount of progress in combating that
what was post 9/11 the principle problem
which was funding coming out of Saudi
Arabia Stewart famously said if he could
snap his fingers and and there was
financing in Saudi Arabia that would
make all the difference or something
along those lines that actually did not
make him so popular among the with the
ambassador in Saudi at the time but but
by the time I got there in 2009 the
Saudis had shifted quite significantly
in their perspective on this issue and
in their willingness and ability to work
with the US I then had the opportunities
to try to build on on those efforts what
we did in my my ten-year Treasury which
spanned from oh nine to fifteen was
principally to work bilaterally and I
think this bears on the question of how
important it is on the further to be a
unified GCC
by and large with some very minor
exceptions all of the efforts that we
undertook were bilateral with the Saudis
with the Emiratis with the Bahrainis
with the Cadiz and the cutter ease the
sharing of intelligence information
which is critical to be able to identify
who the terrorists financiers are how
they're raising their money how they're
moving their money that also tended to
be I think I would exclusively as
probably the right word they're
exclusively bilateral the the only
exception in my recollection was we made
some efforts to enlist the Saudis to
work with us in sort of a trilateral
fashion with the Kuwait ease and the
cutter ease and remember a couple of
occasions in particular were we would be
in Saudi speaking with Mohammed bin
Nayef or Abu Ali the folks who were sort
of most important in the finance in the
interior ministry there on the terrorist
financing issue to try to get them to
essentially to put pressure with us on
the cutter ease and the Kuwait ease that
did not work so well to not put too fine
a point on it and I and I think was for
a variety of reasons but working in a
trilateral fashion didn't work and
working in the GCC more more broadly was
not something that we really try to try
to pursue so I so the current situation
in the Gulf right now where you see I
think a real potential for the GCC to
splinter and for Qatar to go its way and
the Saudis and the Emiratis their way
and with the other states sort of
falling in line I think that itself
isn't the problem I think the bigger
problem is that you have Carter which
had been making some progress in recent
years in prosecuting terrorists fanciers
in being a little bit more
forward-leaning in in its efforts no
longer feeling that it's in the club
inside the tent and we lose a little bit
of the sort of moral suasion that comes
from a combined effort of folks in the
Gulf and so that's that's what I'm
worried about in the in the current
situation is that you the progress that
we have seen with the countries in the
last couple of years which has been sort
of hard-won lots of efforts from
Treasury and from State and others to
move the countries along that that will
begin to to recede and then I'll just
make one final point we can pick up on
it later the other thing that you all
know happened recently in the Gulf that
I think has significant implications for
the future of counter-terrorist
financing is the switch in the Crown
Prince in Saudi Arabia so Mohammed bin
Salman is now the Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Nayef has been ousted and also outed
from his position as the Minister of
Interior mana the knife was a stalwart
partner of the United States in
combating terrorist financing and really
bringing Saudi Arabia to a point where
it was doing you know a quite good job
in sort across the board in combating
terrorist finance and with him no longer
in position in interior ministry and no
longer really in position in the
government's we have lost United States
has lost a key partner in this effort
and I think that's that is something
that we need to watch very carefully
because it's you know it was obviously
not him by himself but his position in
that in that family's position in that
government was enormous ly important on
the other hand Mohammed bin Salman who
doesn't have much of a track record in
the terrorist financing arena but does
promise some modernization in in Saudi
Arabia both economic and you know
potentially the role of the clerical
establishment and sort of the so
hardcore Wahhabi up
that that you're all familiar with and
that Saudi has been promulgating around
the world if he is successful in
moderating that to some extent that
could have a beneficial impact in in
terrorist financing not just in Saudi
but more broadly around the around the
Arab world so why don't I stop there and
turn it back great thank you David and
we will get back to this question
dynamics between states maybe even
within States as with our conversation
proceeds so Kate over to you and you can
assess for us the risks you see and
opportunities if there are any we have
been recognized great first thank you -
ambassador sash and the Arab Gulf states
for hosting this panel and inviting me
to join I'm really honored to be up here
with with David and Juan who have been
great friends and mentors over over many
years
and and I have to say speaking after the
two of them I have to agree with you
know a lot of what they said but I think
I'm going to find a couple of points -
to push on a little bit I think that I
you know I agree with with with David
that Saudi Arabia and and the UAE have
sought for years to kind of galvanize
Qatari action against the terrorist
financier is that were operating and
continue to operate in Qatar and that
they've felt that there's a there's a
sense that the Qatar ease don't share
the same threat perception as as Saudi
in the UAE this is in a way this desire
to pursue at different times what were
multilateral attempts whether the the
trilateral attempt that that David
mentioned or in other iterations GCC
joint efforts to designate Hezbollah as
a terrorist organization and have
implementing mechanisms that went along
with that commitments that were made at
the Camp David summit under the Obama
administration to pursue multilateral
joint efforts on counter terrorist
financing and Iranian Malena activity in
the region these desires - to bring the
Gulf states together to try to - to get
at
a more common threat perception
associated with this activity the the
repeated kind of inability to do that as
reflected in the current rift I think
and so that's that's how it's a part of
this current rift as well I think that
it's important to note that cutter has
taken some action against Ayers
financing as David said as well that
they've taken action both against
individuals you know they've said you
and listed individuals that their assets
have been frozen that there's travel
bans in place and that there have been
some prosecutions and also
systematically they've passed
legislation to better regulate charities
to better regulate cyber activity to
criminalize certain types of fundraising
or expression on on social media but
that there are a few signs of what
specific actions they've taken under
this legislation or really a lot of
details about what prosecutions or other
law enforcement efforts there have been
and I think that's where in lies an
opportunity out of this rift and the
role that that Saudi and the UAE
partially through the the list that they
published a couple weeks ago of I think
it was 49 individuals and a number of
entities here and I think lies an
opportunity to continue to press Qatar
to act against first of all the UN
designated individuals to act to make
sure they're no longer able to to
actively finance or facilitate in Qatar
I think one option one good thing would
be that Qatar implemented or adopted a
national anti-terrorism committee a
number of years ago and it's placed
within the the Ministry of Interior
although it's an interagency body with
representatives from various part of the
Qatar e-government that this committee
actually has the ability to designate
terrorist financier is beyond what is at
the UN and that propagation of such the
list by Qatar could help clarify some of
the the actions or some of the unclear
signals that you see when you really dig
into what for example the State
Department is
said on one hand that cutter shut down a
charity linked to al-qaeda and Syria
called model sham and 2015 but then just
this March in a designation release
designation of actually a Kuwaiti
individual who is an Astra financier
that he was working with the individual
who had run that that Qatari charity
that was saddle copy who ran it so
despite the fact that the charity has
been shut down that individual continues
to finance or to facilitate terrorist
financing activity so I think that
there's there's a lot of unclear signals
and this is an opportunity to get some
clarity on that great thank you very
much Kate let me for a moment then just
kind of open the aperture a little bit
more broadly and see if I can't bring in
a little bit of what Washington's
thinking maybe and this and some other
regional players at least one other
regional player that's on our minds as
well and and Marcel noted in here
introductory March that there was a lot
of interest in the White House on
counter terrorist financing and it was
interesting at the day the readout the
White House issued after President Trump
spoke to regional leaders on July 2nd
there was five sentences and there were
two mentions made of his really the
decisive focus on counter-terrorist
financing so it was clearly on his mind
my question is we see the rhetoric we
hear the rhetoric do we detect any
change in focus or policies on the
ground that will distinguish this White
House approach to counter terrorist
financing from say you know his
predecessor or others and to what extent
do we see this targeting Iran since your
violence so largely it is largely on the
president's mind when he looks out at
the Arab Gulf and Beyond there in the
Persian Gulf region what about that and
and do we see any any shifts that we can
detect the Damona is still too early to
know and I'll invite one if you want to
start with that yeah well to me it's
incredibly refreshing because I remember
I started back before 9/11 at the
Treasury where it was hard to get a seat
at the table when talking about these
issues and to see both through the Bush
administration and the Obama
administration now the Trump
administration the centrality of
terrorist financing in in many ways for
those of us who were true believers as
to the importance of these issues
it's it's very heartening and the fact
that it was such a centerpiece of the
president's recent visit to the to Saudi
Arabia again a testament to the
importance of these themes and issues I
think I think first and foremost the
fact that this is such a principal issue
from a regional perspective that's
perhaps not altogether different from
the Obama administration or the Bush
administration but the fact that they've
come out of the box so strong and and
full throated around the issues of
terrorist financing is significant
because it does put a marker down that
this is going to be an issue that the
administration even if they don't have
an articulated strategy yet will have to
contend with and end and grapple with
over